die wucht der 2 corona welle erfasst
ende november auch die neuen häuser der
katholischen kliniken in bonn
in sankt marien werden mit den
steigenden infektionszahlen immer mehr
cupid 19 patienten in der
intensivstation aufgenommen
seit märz haben sie hier alles gegeben
trotz fehlender schutzausrüstung neue
hygienevorschriften haufenweise
überstunden wie viele ihrer kolleginnen
und kollegen hatte piccards einen
monatelangen marathon hinter sich
corona patienten die beatmet werden
müssen nicht nur medizinisch und
pflegerisch intensiv betreut werden
sondern auch menschlich das kostet zeit
jedes mal bevor lipica zum patienten
geht muss sie ihre spezielle
schutzkleidung anlegen
gerade corona patienten drücken oft den
ruf knopf viele menschen leiden unter
angst wenn sie sich aufhalten müssen und
dann die türen zu gewinnen mit und
überall tote und tiff und natürlich ist
auch diese situation mit co wird ins
krankenhaus zu kommen dann hat eine
intensivstation zu müssen irgendwie was
von sehr vielen menschen als unheimlich
bedrohlich empfunden
selbstverständlich und insofern ja kann
sein dass wir bis zu zwölfmal oder also
halb wann immer jemand sich meldet und
uns braucht müssen wir halt dann ein 60
jähriger patient mit einem schweren
verlauf muss mehrmals am tag gedreht
werden damit er sich nicht wund liegt
dafür sind mindestens drei pflegekräfte
notwendig nach der ersten corona welle
versprach die bundesregierung eine
prämie von etwa 1500 euro
doch längst nicht alle bekamen den
sogenannten corona bonus
durchschnittlich 3200 euro brutto
verdienen deutsche pflegekräfte im monat
im august wurde eine tariferhöhung von
bis zu zehn prozent für die nächsten
beiden jahre beschlossen
verbindlich aber nur für die kommunalen
krankenhäuser
doch geld allein reicht nicht um den
beruf langfristig attraktiv zu machen
sagt lilly peters nein zu mehr geld und
das wäre sicherlich auch gerecht zu
sagen wir müssen mehr verdienen als wir
das tun nur sie kriegen nicht das über
jahre ausgeglichen wenn bedingungen
nicht stimmen
man kann nicht 30 patienten zu zweit zum
beispiel betreuen dass das ist einfach
ich weiß nicht wie das möglich sein soll
und das ist über jahre glaube ich
ausgesetzt worden
in zahlreichen studien analysierte
professor jürgen wasem das
gesundheitssystem
der ökonom kommt zu keiner guten bilanz
das krankenhaus ist nicht nur wegen der
möglicherweise zu schlechten bezahlung
der pflegekräfte unattraktiv wir haben
auch im europäischen vergleich einen
sehr schlechten personalschlüssel das
liegt daran dass viele krankenhäuser zu
lasten der pflege gespart haben wir sind
europäer ich ziemlich weit unten was die
anzahl der pflegekräfte die patienten
angeht deutschlandweit fehlen in der
pflege etwa 80.000 stellen die arbeit
muss auf weniger schultern verteilt
werden im europäischen vergleich steht
deutschland schlecht da
hier betreut eine pflegekraft pro
schicht durchschnittlich 10,3 patienten
in der schweiz sind es nur 5,4 in den
niederlanden 4,9 und in norwegen sogar
nur 3,8 patienten kliniken wurden von
der politik zum sparen gezwungen oft auf
kosten des personals bei lilly platz
hört sich das so an die stationsleiterin
ist auf den guten willen angewiesen wenn
sie schichten füllen muss ihre
kolleginnen und kollegen springen oft
ein obwohl sie schon längst an der
belastungsgrenze sind verzichten
also sehen hier die gelben felder sind
dann doch da sind dann noch einige im
urlaub auch im dezember aber
die meisten jetzt schon in aussicht
gestellt als wenn wirklich diese
pandemie sich verschlimmern würde dass
sie ohne mit der wimper zu zucken aus
dem urlaub wiederkommen würden
[Musik]
der chefarzt thomas scheck sieht mit
sorge wie seine klinik immer voller wird
corona patienten machen bundesweit
bisher nur einen kleinen teil von nicht
einmal fünf prozent aus doch sie müssen
oft wochenlang beatmet werden und liegen
damit länger auf intensivstationen als
andere patienten elf und zwölf
intensivbetten sind hier belegt wenn
weitere chor ohne patienten kommen die
beatmet werden müssen wird es brenzlig
auch personell das heißt wir werden wenn
wir es brauchen und das pflegepersonal
op pflegepersonal auf intensivstationen
einsetzen mit der folge dass wir
natürlich bestimmte operationen nicht
mehr machen können das ist jetzt nicht
ganz trivial weil der überwiegende
anteil dieser operationen die gemacht
werden die müssen gemacht werden
operationen aufschieben ist nicht nur
medizinisch quartal auch finanziell
zwei stockwerke über der intensivstation
hat der geschäftsführer der kliniken
sein büro ging morell stöhnt unter der
finanziellen last auch seine häuser
mussten kapazitäten für coop 19
patienten bereithalten und planbare
operationen reduzieren
monatelang zumindestens nach den
jetzigen hochrechnungen machen wir zirka
sechs bis acht millionen euro defizit in
diesem jahr im sommer war für die
öffentlichkeit corona weit weg aber in
den krankenhäusern corona die ganze zeit
präsent und wir haben natürlich auch
darüber nachgedacht
beziehungsweise es auch umgesetzt wie
können wir uns auf diese situation
besser einstellen das was wir natürlich
nicht hinbekommen ist innerhalb dieser
kurzen zeit den grundsätzlichen
personalmangel
den können wir nicht beheben den gab's
ja auch vor corona schon
das jahrzehntelange sparen am personal
rächt sich in der krise und gerade jetzt
ist der pflegeberuf besonders riskant
etwa 31.000 beschäftigte haben sich mit
corona infiziert bei der intensiv
pflegerin doreen wittenberg läuft die
angst sich anzustecken immer mit man
macht sich natürlich immer gedanken wenn
man jetzt rein geht ob der schutz jetzt
ausreicht sagen es meine ob man jetzt
irgendwas mit nach hause nimmt und da
vielleicht jemanden ansteckt der
vielleicht nicht ganz so fit ist
das ist schon da ja das robert koch
institut empfiehlt sogar ohne positive
pflegekräfte sollen weiter arbeiten
gehen wenn in der einrichtung ein
relevanter personalmangel vorliegt also
fast überall
ähnliche probleme auch in den
gesundheitsämtern
miltenberg in unterfranken ende november
bis dahin höchste corona inzidenz im
landkreis 217 fälle auf 100.000
einwohner ein hotspot auch hier im
gesundheitsamt kommen die
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter an ihre
grenzen
barbara bertl visa und dagmar kempf
gehören zur stammbesetzung
seit acht monaten oft auch am wochenende
sind sie im dauereinsatz
[Musik]
ja ich kann sie gar nicht erreichen
haben sie noch keine informationen
bekommen neben kindergarten und sie war
noch gar nicht zum testen gewesen haben
wir positives ergebnis bekommen das
haben wir jetzt auch noch nie gehabt
dann kann ich dir zu verzeichnen alles
stabil können dass sie mir das mal zu
schicken
per e mail ein telefonat nach dem
anderen und auch solche geschichten sind
immer wieder dabei als zum beispiel
barbara werte wie seine mutter in
quarantäne schicken muss an dem tag wo
und hat natürlich gemeint also das ist
so was was mir natürlich auch noch lange
im kopf präsent haben die pandemie
zwingt das gesundheitsamt immer weiter
personal aufzustocken
auf dem parkplatz hinter dem landratsamt
liefern lkw bürocontainern hier sollen
bald bundeswehrkräfte arbeiten unter
stammpersonal zu entlassen
personalmangel auch in städten wie
erfurt
das gesundheitsamt hat mit unterstützung
der bundeswehr ein mobiles testteam
eingerichtet
[Musik]
gepackt haben wir alles ich habe lieber
deutschen dabei
anastasia und ihr neues team fahren
jeden tag in die hotspots der stadt da
hin wo neue infektionsherde vermutet
werden
der plan ist eng getaktet trotz der
unterstützung kommen sie hier mit dem
testen kaum noch hinterher
200 bis 300 ungefähr auch am tag kann
schon mal passieren wird
heute geht zu alten menschen die es
nicht selbst in ein testcenter schaffen
eine hochsensible situation für alle
beteiligten
vom
diese einmal genau dann zweiter
aufgenommen im kampf gegen die pandemie
zieht das gesundheitsamt kräfte aus
allen bereichen zusammen
die untersuchung im kita-bereich in den
schulen und die aufgaben können wir
nicht wahrnehmen im moment die bleiben
liegen
aufgaben wie schuluntersuchungen
suchtprävention psychosoziale beratungen
um die sich das gesundheitsamt in
normalen zeiten kümmert vieles bleibt
notgedrungen auf der strecke meint
erfurts bürgermeisterin anke hofmann
domke das sei der preis für die
bekämpfung der pandemie und wir haben
nach der pandemie spüren dass die
aufgaben die jetzt nur zum teil erfüllt
werden können und in der zukunft
natürlich auch probleme bereiten
was passieren kann wenn die lage dort
außer kontrolle gerät hat das ernst von
bergmann klinikum in potsdam in früher
erleben müssen mit 1000 betten und 3.500
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern im
normalbetrieb ist es das größte
krankenhaus brandenburgs im märz gab es
hier die ersten und schlimmsten
ausbrüche von chromit 19 in einem
hospital 45 patienten zumeist ältere
starben
bis heute laufen ermittlungen wie es
dazu kommen konnte
noch immer sitzt der schock tief die
verantwortlichen hätten konsequenzen
gezogen sagt michael obert leiter der
intensivmedizin material umgang mit
schutzausrüstung um mit diesen
infektiösen patienten auch da haben wir
natürlich in den letzten monaten viel
gelernt und haben auch unser personal
dementsprechend geschult das sind sachen
die die welt trainiert haben und die
sich jetzt auszahlen eine kuh mit 19
patienten wird für die verlegung
vorbereitet denn die zahl der
intensivpatienten steigt und die betten
werden knapp und auch hier fehlt
personal
die patienten sollen 70 kilometer
entfernten lungen und beatmungs zentrum
bad welt sich gebracht werden um in der
nähe von berlin wieder ein bett frei zu
schaffen denn auch dort spitzt sich die
lage geradezu die klinikgruppe ernst von
bergmann gehört zu 100 prozent der stadt
potsdam und muss als gemeinnützige gmbh
keine gewinne abwerfen und doch stoßen
auch kommunale kliniken wie sie an ihre
finanziellen grenzen
weil die länder ihren verpflichtungen in
die kliniken zu investieren nicht
nachkommen so der vorwurf von experten
und krankenhausträgern
wir können das als kommunen als
öffentliche hand als träger nicht
alleine stemmen
und wir werden die klare finanzielle
unterstützung der länder brauchen das
ist ja kein brandenburgisches problem
das ist ein deutschlandweites problem
dass das war es seitens der länder in
die krankenhäuser investiert investiert
wird zu wenig zu gering ist von der
gesamtsumme
die probleme werden auch nach der
pandemie bleiben
eine wesentliche ursache das 2003
eingeführte abrechnungssystem der
fallpauschalen
danach wird für jede medizinische
leistung ein festgelegter betrag gezahlt
darin enthalten sind auch die gesamten
pflegeleistungen erst 2020 wurden die
pflegekosten aus der fallpauschale
herausgenommen seitdem werden diese
extra vergütet trotzdem machen viele
kliniken verluste der kaufmännische
geschäftsführer des ernst von bergmann
klinikums dem steckel kritisiert dass
die kliniken alleine gelassen werden
tatsächlich haben die krankenhäusern
akutes liquiditätsproblem
wir haben teure ausgaben in
schutzmaßnahmen in der bohr testung und
im moment keinen die qualitäts ausgleich
weshalb viele krankenhäuser angehalten
sind eben die normale versorgung so
lange wie es irgend möglich ist maximal
auszulasten und eher wenig vorhaltung
für kurve zugetragen
die medizinischen arbeitskräfte müssten
dringend in den mittelpunkt des
gesundheitssystems gerückt werden
denn am ende sind sie es die aus
patientinnen und patienten wieder
gesunde menschen machen
also ich glaube müssen uns nach der
pandemischen situation umgehen
miteinander hinsetzen um anreizsysteme
zu schaffen die den beruf im
medizinischen bereich zu arbeiten als
pflegerin als pfleger wochen anderen
berufen wieder attraktiver gestaltet da
ist den letzten jahren eine menge ins
rutschen gekommen und das hat nicht nur
was mit bezahlung zu punkten nach der
pandemie
das wird noch lange dauern und die
pflegekräfte noch lange belasten
dazu kommt ein weiteres problem wer die
schwere krankheit übersteht der braucht
oft eine wochenlange rehabilitation
das reha klinik zentrum bad sulza in
thüringen hat sich genau darauf
spezialisiert viele gelesene cupid 19
patienten wurden hier aufgenommen und es
werden wohl bald noch viel mehr wie
wichtig eine schnelle reha therapie ist
das hat gerd gerstenberger am eigenen
leib erlebt im herbst lag er zwei wochen
lang mit einer corona infektion auf der
intensivstation
mir ging es sehr schlecht ich hätte ein
herzinfarkt durch kurve zwei jungen in
berlin durch kurven und eine abordnung
entgangen weil ich diese diese trainings
maske aufgesetzt habe
da ordnen sie gegen einen widerstand an
haben sie das gefühl sie ersticken
gleich das habe ich mir zwei mal runter
größen dann haben sie mir eröffnet weil
sie wenn sie das nicht schaffen
die alternative ist dann
luftröhrenschnitt und künstliches koma
mit seinen griechen zittern
das wollte ich nicht hab ich nur logisch
aber ich hätte nie geglaubt dass ich das
überhaupt schaffen überleben ist hätte
ich nicht geklappt viele patienten
kämpfen auch lange nach der infektion
mit den spätfolgen wie dauerhafte
erschöpfung gedächtnis oder
konzentrationsstörungen
auch psychische probleme machen den
betroffenen zu schaffen
heute in der nacht wenn sie auf der
intensivstation liegen nicht schlafen
können
die die geräusche von den geräten
unentwegt tag und nacht das hören sie in
den ohren und dann gehen die gedanken
durch die zeit vergeht nicht also dass
ich habe gedacht dass das kumulieren
seiten also die die psychische belastung
ist schön und sie fühlen sich so
ausgegrenzt und das macht mit ihnen was
glaubst du gar nicht
das läuft ab wie er film sie denken aber
nicht dass sie darbt rolle spielen
traumatische erfahrungen für den
buchhalter und eine enorme mehrbelastung
für die reha kraft kerstin scheibe es
ist mehr stress ist definitiv mehr
stress ist mehr arbeit und man spürt es
auch also sowohl bei den schwestern bei
den ärzten bis zum therapien
pflegepersonal selbst die
reinigungskräfte also es geht quer durch
die anspannung ist da aber wir haben
jetzt die situation und es geht nur
entweder durch und nicht
wegen der abstandsregeln sind aktuell
nur kleine therapiegruppen möglich dass
verdoppelt den arbeitsaufwand der
pflegekräfte der ganze klinikalltag
muster auf den kopf gestellt werden
klagt geschäftsführer marc förster
das bindet personal wir müssen aber
dennoch mit dem personal was uns gegeben
ist diese aufgaben bewältigen
das führt natürlich dazu dass das
personal wirklich an leistungsgrenzen
kommt in bad sulza gibt es 65 betten für
lungenpatienten wie gerd gerstenberger
in ganz deutschland stehen etwa 3000
solcher reha plätze bereit
das klingt erst mal viel aktuell
befinden sich aber schon mehr als 4100
19 patienten auf intensivstationen
längst sind es aber nicht nur die
schweren fälle die dringend eine reha
benötigen meint gerd gerstenberger arzt
professor höffken
im prinzip braucht jeder eine reha der
nach bestehen einer akuten infektion
weiterhin schwierigkeiten probleme oder
beschwerden hat und das ist nicht
abhängig davon ob er in die zahl eine
schwere infektionserkrankung hatte das
können auch patienten seien mit einer
sehr leichten infektion die dennoch
quasi nach dem überstehen der akuten
infektion plötzlich neue beschwerden
dicker für post cockpit 19 patienten wie
ihn ist eine reha der einzige weg wieder
in den alltag zurückzufinden
da ich ja noch arbeiten gehen zwei
männer woche und die firma nicht so
lange im stich lassen wollte obwohl ich
eigentlich nicht so weitergehen
aber die haben ja nur gelegt dass ich zu
reagieren sollte weil es allein niemals
schaffen wird ich möchte hier noch
möglichkeit möglichst wieder das leisten
können was ich vorher geleistet habe und
das ist mein einziges ziel eigentlich
damit auch andere wieder in ihr altes
leben zurück finden braucht es
langwierige reha maßnahmen und gut
geschultes personal
um kostendeckend zu arbeiten benötigen
die rehakliniken geld aber das steht
nicht überall ausreichend zur verfügung
die korona pandemie hat die schwächen
von einem der teuersten
gesundheitssysteme der welt offen gelegt
in krankenhäusern in gesundheitsämtern
und in reha kliniken
[Musik]
überall fehlt personal dieser mangel ist
so schnell nicht zu beheben
aber sparen auf dem rücken derer die
täglich an ihre leistungsgrenzen gehen
darf kein modell mehr für die zukunft
sein
[Musik]